with it might be a good idea to revisit
the topic of text compression which was
visited for the first time in the
original compression video on the
computer file channel some of you in the
comments made the point to which I must
plead guilty that in trying to explain
things I perhaps over simplified a
little to take the discussion on and
make some more general points about text
in general how compressible it is what
are good and bad ways to do it and how
it has all become really quite big
business over the past thirty odd years
since it became commonly available well
the two names we ought to write down to
start with on text compression a two
gentleman and we wrote a classic paper
on it called zip and Lempel but most
people certainly in english-speaking
world seem to find it easier to say
Lempel Ziv rather than zip Lempel and so
very while in very widely now is known
as the lz77 method let's say we've got
something like this the computer file
channel handles computer topics in my
original explanation i put to you the
idea of having a dictionary of
well-known words and buzz phrases up at
the top of the file with pointers to
where all these words occurred and if in
doubt use the pointers for repeats of
certain words well the West actually
done in perhaps is not dissimilar in
principle to that but the details are
even more clever in terms of achieving
maximum compression cutting down file
size and so on what a typical lzd
compressor will do is it will work its
way through all of the text that you
need to compress and will actually look
for sequences of characters that recur
and over again and we'll attempt to
reuse them as much as it possibly can
it doesn't overtly make a dictionary
entry by putting them somewhere special
but just by leaving these strings of
text in place it can reuse stuff in
place here we've got the word computers
8 characters but a compressor could
remember that it has seen that string of
characters already as a subset of the
string computer file the thought
immediately occurs 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
characters are identical here to what
they are at the beginning of that word
can't we use that in some way and cut
down the length of this and what the
Lempel Ziv method does is it uses a
pointer and in that composite pointer it
points back to where the phrase first
occurred and it also notes down how long
the phrase was at that point now I'm
going to denote these pointers with a
notation that looks like this I'll call
it J and L J being the jump it's a
relative jump how many characters back
would I need to go to encounter this
word computer somewhere else and when I
do get back to that character position
in the file then how long will the
string of characters be now I must
emphasize if you look inside a Lempel
Ziv file you will not see pointy
brackets let alone numbers or characters
here this is just my notation to try and
illustrate what is going on in actual
fact this pointer might well be at it's
very simplest let's say it's 16 bits to
8-bit bytes if you like
the details say it's a little bit more
complicated than this even in two bytes
I might be able to do some magic here
that will read place eight bytes in the
word computer with a two by two
composite pointer of this sort now what
I have to do is to say right
where did computer occur relative to
where it is now housed in just a single
space here although it might not look
like it one two three four five six
seven eight we'll assume there isn't a
new line here but there is a caret in
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen sixteen seventeen eighteen
nineteen Twenty twenty six and twenty
eight twenty thirty a relative backward
jump of thirty characters there was and
put a little partition here a one two
three four five six seven eight by word
so there we go those numbers those
integers are cheerfully representable
within eight bits each so I could take
out computer here and replace it with in
my notation thirty comma eight thinking
around is a little bit it should be
pretty clear you've got a trade off if
we're going to allow a total of sixteen
bits to take the jump and also the
length of the string you're pointing at
now you can trade off that internal
boundary because eight bits to the power
eight is 256 so on either side of this
notional divide you've got the ability
to hold integers from 0 to 255 now in
actual fact there are not many
situations in western European languages
at least where you get massively long
words repeated again and again and again
so the attitude taken in many practical
implementations of this tends to be
let's keep that pointed out string
fairly short so if it is a long word we
might have to do a few of these pointers
but better to have a long jump back
possibility that means that you can keep
reusing words up to well what let's say
we do a partition like this four bits
here twelve bits here two to the power
12 is 4096 note to those of you that
keep writing in on comments saying hey
professor what should I do I'm just a
high school and I want to do computer
science at University what's the best
preparation my statement will be learn
your powers of two backwards upside down
inside out learn your powers of two
I want while you're at it learn your
sixteen times table so you'll be very
quick at doing hexadecimal I was forced
to learn my 16 times table at school not
because we did hexadecimal but because
in those days there were 16 ounces in a
pound of sugar or whatever so one 16 is
16 to 16 to 32 3 16 is 48 and so on it's
worth it anyway what we're saying there
is that 2 to power 12 is 4096 2 to the
power 4 is 16 you can encode in here a
string that is anything if you like 1 to
16 bytes long but you can have a
relative backward jump 4096 characters
that is a pretty good trade-off what
will happen of course is that if your
pointer back to the substring computer
gets to be more than 4096 characters
away then your encoder will have to
remember and put in its mental
dictionary a new instance of the word
computer that can be referred back to so
imagine this happening not just for
words like computer but for words like
channel 4 handles for substrings of
handles called hand and so on all the
time the thing is preparing in a sense
to make a dictionary entry of anything
that seems suitable so it can be
referred back to again and again and
again so what one's saying here is that
even with this simple model you are
being able to replace a multi-byte
entity by a 2 byte pointer
probabilities probabilities
probabilities the three P's getting your
probability model right for the material
you are coping with is the heart of
getting a really successful compression
the web browser looks that and goes that
is JavaScript code I'm gonna run that